Let's consider the universal
gravitational law a little bit
more.
Let's consider two
objects in space.
Let's say this is the sun,
and we have the earth here
or the earth and the moon.
And of course, they're
orbiting each other.
So we can pick a coordinate
system that goes radially.
And so we're going to have
an r hat direction here,
and we're going to call this the
r hat direction between objects
1 and 2.
What forces are acting
on this little moon here?
Well, it's the gravitational
force going inward.
It's force of 1, 2,
F1 2, on object 2,
due to the interaction
between bodies 1 and 2.
For that, we can write down the
universal gravitational law,
F1 2 equals minus G, the
gravitational constant, m1,
m2 of r1 2 squared.
That one is the distance between
the two objects times r1 2 hat.
And the minus goes, actually,
with the unit vector
here, because the force goes
in the opposite direction
from our r hat.
Let's now consider here
is the earth again.
And we're going to move the
moon or a little moon rock right
to the surface of the earth.
And we want to now calculate
and consider what kind of force
this act on this
moon rock, and what
is the gravitational
acceleration that this moon
rock on the surface of
the earth is experiencing?
So we have the earth.
Earth has one earth radius,
and it has an earth mass.
And our moon rock
has the mass m.
And we know, from this exercise
here already, that, of course,
this gravitational force
is acting on our moon rock
as well.
That hasn't changed.
What we are now
considering in addition
is that this moon rock
is also experiencing
a gravitational acceleration
due to this force,
and that goes inward as well.
So it is experiencing an mg.
And we know that that is
the same as the magnitude
of this force here.
So we can equate that with G,
and then we have the earth mass
and the mass of the moon rock
times the distance squared,
so an earth radius squared.
And from that, we
already see that a, we
can cancel out the small
m, so the moon rock,
and we get to g here.
So we can calculate the
gravitational acceleration,
which is capital G earth mass
over earth radius squared.
So if we have this
kind of information,
we can determine the
gravitational acceleration.
And of course, it will
change, depending on which
object we are considering.
It would be different if
we plug in the solar mass
and the solar radius or the
moon mass and the moon radius,
if we consider an
astronaut standing here
on the moon's surface.
Now let's put some numbers
into this equation.
So we have g is
capital G. That's
the gravitational constant.
We have 6.67, 10 to 11, and
then we have Newton and 1
over kilogram squared
and mass squared times
the earth mass, 5.97
10 to 24 kilograms.
And then we have
to divide this over
through the earth
radius, 6.37 10 to the 6.
And we have to square that, and
we have to square the meters.
If we calculate this, we get to
9.81 meter per second squared.
And surely you have
seen this number before.
This number can
either be calculated,
if you know capital G, the
gravitational constant,
or you can determine that
gravitational acceleration
through an experiment.
And together with the earth
mass and the earth radius,
you can actually calculate the
gravitational constant there.